the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody to round four of the
2022 spring chess classic i'm
grandmaster alejandro ramirez here with
my good friend grandmaster christian
carilla to bring you all of the action
of the day alejandro always a pleasure
to commentate these exciting games with
you here from the beautiful studio in st
louis it's always good to be here with a
good friend to look at some good chess
might not be the singfield cup it might
not be the us champs but it's an
important stepping stone for many of
these players it's a way for many of the
2600 plus grand masters to find
experience to find rating points to find
tournaments where they can catapult
themselves to the very lead and break
that 2700 barrier well alejandro let's
uh take a look at the standings after
round number three we have ray robson in
group a leading as well tied for first
place with aram jacobian these players
are just simply playing marvelous chess
up to this point two and a half out of
three jeffrey shang in the third
position sold third position with two
points and then a big tie for fourth
position we have sam savion ilya nishnik
darius zvierch and hans nima alexandre
was able to save half a point yesterday
against ilya nishnik but still that only
puts him at one point he is in clear
eighth and slightly luckless misha
antipov and camille dragoon both lost
with the white pieces yesterday to dario
spirits in a very long fight and camille
dragoon losing to ray robson also after
an intense fight and they find
themselves with only half a point
meanwhile in group b
in group b we have an authoritarian
leader and that is chris redka with
three out of three points christopher
you sold second position with two points
and then we have a big tie for third
position with one and a half points we
have robert hungaski el-shan muradiabadi
jj alimarandi your student alejandro
titus strema vichus sam connie and
abimanyu mishra slightly luckless have
been armani khalian who's had some good
positions was able to draw against
christopher you yesterday but we thought
he had a very promising position there
with the white pieces and harshed raja
strong grandmaster but has been unable
to find his first half a point here in
st louis so far surely he's gonna try to
bounce back in tournament as we see the
tournament hall currently in action very
fighting chess up there and everybody's
very tense remember they have already
been playing for two and a half hours so
certainly the tension is rising the
format for you it's two tournaments
they're both round robins of 10 players
each the time controller is a classic
time control 90 minutes or 40 moves with
an extra 30 seconds started given for
move one and once you reach that move 40
you get an extra 30 minutes also the
players are not allowed to mutually
agree to a draw in less than 40 moves
they cannot find a repetition they can
find a perpetual to make that elusive
draw but they cannot mutually agree to
it this is going to ensure that we have
a very combative event let's take a look
at the schedule it's very simple one
round a day and every day we start at 1
pm commentary starts two and a half
hours later at 3 30 central standard
time and remember that because of the
possibility of playoffs
first place will be determined on over
the board playoff we will be starting
the last round on thursday slightly
earlier two hours earlier our commentary
will start at 1 30 instead of 3 30 but
of course we will be bringing you all of
that action
also make sure you join the conversation
on social media we are very active
specifically on twitter you can find us
and send us your questions at
spring chess classic also our show is
broadcast on youtube as well as on
twitch on twitch if you donate more than
75 dollars well that's going to allow us
to support an up-and-coming player from
the scholastic player all the way up
eddie amount helps and remember all of
those bits donation subs they go
directly to a kid
you will be helping their chess
programmer you will be helping their
careers chess players don't worry they
are not going directly to us they're
going to a good cause so please
subscribe to the channel and help us out
there let's take a look at the pairings
for the day obviously we're going to
start with the a group where we have
some key matchups samsung against daryu
spirits are already a classic of the us
championship tournaments they'll be
facing here for the spring chess classic
and they'll certainly be facing each
other in uh the u.s championship settled
to be happening in october here in saint
louis arahakobian against misha and
thibaut is a battle of collegiate chess
around hakobian currently representing
webster and mikhail antipa representing
the university of missouri hence the man
is playing against alex london ilya
nishnik is playing as camille dragoon
but our matchup of the day without any
doubt is this one ray robson against
jeffrey shank both of them relatively
young players over 20 but way below 30
and they have already made names for
themselves here at the san luis chassis
playing many many many events against
each other jeffrey is currently one of
the top players in the world not just in
the country but still trying to find his
stable form over 2700 he's had a little
bit of trouble finding uh his stability
up there and he's currently playing
against ray who's simply playing
magnificent chess meanwhile in group b
we have a clear leader there but let's
see who is trying to fight to catch him
it's christopher you that's playing with
the white pieces against jj ali miranda
harshed roger trying to find his first
half point of the tournament against the
stream of issues meanwhile sam hanin is
going to be playing as the youngest
grand master in the world amiban
ubishira iron mikhailian is playing as
elsa maria the body and yet again we
have a clear matchup of the day robert
hungaski the one of the most experienced
players in the tournament participating
in events from around the world
currently sitting at 50 after losing
that first game with the white piece
against christopher you bouncing back on
day number two but is currently playing
somebody that has been scintillating
over the board he's been clean he's been
precise he's been methodical and he's
currently sitting on a very well
deserved three out of three can he make
it farther for christian your boy chris
replica has been shining absolutely
alejandro well let's take a look at this
game as you were mentioning alejandro
robert tungaski is a very experienced
player he's been playing quite a lot
recently and he's definitely trending
upwards he has been winning tournament
after tournament and he
gained a lot of rating points as well in
the past year right now he's facing
chris repca the battle of two gm's chris
repco three out of three extremely
strong performance up to this point he
has had
not a single problem in any of the games
let's see how uh this game played out e4
e6 well this might uh have uh come as a
surprise for robert hungaski because
general chris repco plays either c5 or
e5 in this case he decides for the
french defense d4 d5 now we see e5 c5
this advanced french with e5 which is uh
becoming more and more popular generally
for the past few years knight to c3 or
knight to d2 has been considered to be
the main line e5 was not considered to
be giving white too much of a pull but
in recent times white has found this a
very clever idea of just simply giving
up a pawn sacrificing a pawn in the
center well should black take it
probably not because if you take on c3
after knight takes e3 this bishop will
be landing with a tempo on e3 for
example you can go knight to e7 bishop
to e3 you would love to be able to play
this move d4 that would be a fork
instantaneous fork well
it's not a good move because i can
simply take this uh pawn on d4 you can
take back i can take back and now
unfortunately this bishop on d4 is taboo
because if you take it i'm just simply
going to have this
thematic bishop to b5
attacking the king attacking the queen
as well discovery check that's going to
lose for black instantaneously so of
course you don't want to play this move
uh
d take c3 you don't want to give you
want you don't want to give me too much
speed in my attack so ins instead of
that he played the move bishop to d7
rook to e1 knight to e7
h4 once again still leaving that pawn on
a d4 and now we see rook to c8 h5 knight
to f5 bishop to uh f5 e takes f5 now the
structure has changed of course black
has a weakness on d5 but that's going to
be easily protected by a bishop coming
to e6 it doesn't look like a great
bishop but it's a very good defensive
piece for black knight to c3 bishop to
e6 rook to e3 of course white is
trying to arrange his pieces towards
black's king on the king side after a
short castle knight to f5 bishop to g5
f4 i like this move bishop to g5
provoking the move f4 which closes up
the action of the bishop on c1 which was
a very very important attacking piece
because with the pawn on f2 some bishop
takes h6 sacrifice would have uh been
coming on the board in most of uh
instances
b3 castle bishop to b2 rook to c7 rook
to c1 rook to c8 and to be honest uh
right now it feels like black is taking
over white's attack is not going
anywhere on the king side and black has
his pieces aim towards the pawn
structure on the queen side now we have
knight to c6
and we get this position
this g4 move is a very committal
decision for white and to be honest
alejandro i do not like it we were
discussing this uh game a bit before we
started the broadcast and you were
mentioning this move knight to g3 which
probably would have been a much better
option for white just simply targeting
this pawn on f5 if you have to play the
move g6 well that gives me a hook on
this pawn on g6 and i can just simply
keep this pawn on h5 for the moment and
i can take on a g6 and open the position
on my terms whenever i want to do that
so i think this knight to g3 would have
been a much better solution for white
well he played the move g4 and this just
simply gives up a point and it doesn't
seem like your attack is going anywhere
as white because whenever you're going
to push this pawn on f5 it looks
threatening but it also gives up a lot
of squares specifically a lot of squares
for this bishop on e7 the dark square
bishop to come to g5 enter the fray uh
get closer to the white king and that
will spell trouble for white so now we
have this position a couple of moves
later this is the current position on
the board and it seems like black is
just simply dominating the pair of
bishops extra pawn and the invasion
coming on the c file this is really
looking poorly for white
i feel there was just a bit overzealous
there by robert hungatsuki is strange
he's a very experienced player but
sometimes
time's ticking you don't find a clear
plan he felt that pressure on the clock
looming it wasn't quite there but it was
certainly looming you start feeling very
uncomfortable when you're under 20
minutes and you see that
time control is still far on the horizon
instead of another 20 some moves to make
and you don't really know what to do and
i think g4 was a little desperate a
little
panicky i would even go back as far as
to say
and that currently
he is just in a losing position the pair
of bishops to me are too powerful the
control of the c file the only open file
is tremendous and as you mentioned uh
christian i think white's king might
actually even be weaker than blacks oh
yeah absolutely despite the fact that it
seems those pawns are marching towards
the black king well they're not going
anywhere because as soon as you play
that move f5 your king becomes so much
weaker and it seems like only black can
take advantage of that absolutely all
right let me take a look at another
important game i spotted a very nice
little detail here in the game between
samhainin and abhimanyu mishra and it
shows you just how hard chess is in my
opinion this is a very interesting
position
we call these cadapo positions the
hanging pawn types of positions and the
the way that we analyze a lot of
positions in chess is based on the
structure the pawn structure in this
position and you can see that white has
these pawns
on the fourth rank particularly the ones
in the center these two c4 and d4
they're considered hanging pawns they're
called like that because they can defend
each other but cannot be defended by any
one of their pawns next to each other
adjacent to them and they give
particularly interesting strategical
battles they take up a lot of space
they're able to provide white with a lot
of space and notice that it restricts
black you cannot really access any of
these squares as the black side because
of these hanging pawns creating tension
on the other hand the hanging pawns
themselves constantly require attention
you can see that in this position even a
move like bishop takes f3 might be
considered because if you play knight
takes f3 suddenly nobody's defending c4
that's why the bishop went all the way
to a2 where it's a little bit awkward so
it gives process and it gives cons one
of the biggest pluses of the of the
points as i said controls the fourth
rank here
after the move a5
white said you know the move a5 prevents
a5 from myself it doesn't allow me to
use this hook to pressure the b6 pawn
but you've already moved your pawn from
a7 to a5 why don't i just put my rook on
c1 to b1
pressure this pawn
and say well thank you for the free
pressure i'm still not really sure how
i'm going to make progress but on the
other hand your pieces they're a little
bit on the passive side as long as these
pawns are alive and well protected and
boom came in a strategical idea said i'd
be mind you you know what
check this out
knight d5 is actually a surprisingly
difficult move to meet for white and
it's certainly an easy one to miss why
because your pawns have been guarding
this squares for so long you don't
expect any of black's pieces to jump
into them knight d5 is tactically
justified by the fact that if you take
on d5 and i think with the bishop
you're currently attacking the queen the
queen really does have to move and then
you discover this attack of the queen of
the rook on c3
and if black wins on very important part
and probably the game
and the main point of the move knight d5
is that i'm currently threatening to
take a bishop on c3 with my knight you
don't want to
allow me to do this but if the bishop
retreats to a1 then in this kind of
scenarios the bishop is much more
passively placed and the knight can jump
to b4 block out this file if i felt like
it also take on a2 that is defending the
pawn on c4 and suddenly because this
knight is hopping around instead of
being passive on f6 where it's locking
up its own bishop i think it's black for
clear choice after the move knight d5 i
think i've seen sam play the move bishop
a1 actually and i expect the knight b4
with quite honestly a very strong
advantage for black
out of nowhere almost it seemed like
black and white had about equal
opportunities before the move rook b1
pretty much
not only that it allows this move knight
to d5 but it also locks that bishop on
a2 yeah you can no longer put it to b1
so now 95 knight before just comes with
tempo and you cannot save that bishop on
a2 that's a big problem it's a series of
unfortunate events here for white right
none of this is possible without the
move knight d5 but it must have been a
complete
mind slip a complete blunder uh he
didn't see the move knight d5 coming
it's not like it captures anything
sometimes your mind is not really
thinking along those lines but
strategically it's very important to
keep
blacks pieces at bay they have to be
kept behind the third rank for white to
have the compensation here the more
pieces we exchange the weaker the
hanging pawns become and of course
losing the pair of bishops is no fun
abby manu spotting this very nice knight
d5 very aesthetic move here in this
position and i think that gives him a
strong advantage she's going to be a
clear favorite for the rest of the game
absolutely alejandro i want to point
your attention to this game uh between
christopher you in seoul second position
with two of the three points and ali
marande chen mil-chan your student at
slu ali marande has been having a
topsy-turvy event he started off with a
loss then he bounced back then yesterday
was complete madness on the board and
somehow it finished into a draw but
right now once again he's playing with
the black pieces and we're going into
this position this end game rook and
knight versus rook and knight white has
an extra pawn but as a compensation
black definitely has the more active
pieces right this rook on the second
rank cutting uh the king on g3 also the
knight seems to be much more active now
at this point i feel he made a huge
mistake of course the computer is saying
uh knight to b3 would have been the
right decision
what pieces in this type of end games do
you want to trade that is the biggest
question that you need to ask yourself
when you're playing this type of
positions where
would you like to go into a rook and
game four versus three on the same side
sure that's going to be an easy draw
would you like to go into a knight's end
game four versus three on the same side
no absolutely not because knight and
games resemble very much pawn end games
in which if you have an extra pawn in
general most of the times you're going
to be winning it's the same for knights
even though it looks innocuous white's
advantage four versus three doesn't seem
like you're going to be able to create
that past pawn i'm just going to be able
to slowly squeeze you and this is
exactly what happened in the game we
will see that in just a second knight to
b3 would have been the much better
solution rook to b1 and now rook to d3
attacking the pawn on e3 if you go
knight to c4 now i have a couple of
options
but rook to c3 probably would be the
easiest way out and of course after h4
i'm just simply going to take you're
going to take i'm going to take and this
is an easy draw maybe even black is
slightly better but of course he's going
to end up in a drawing instead of that
he played the move rook to b2 and this
is a huge huge mistake because after
knight to c4 rook to b4 knight to a5 uh
rook takes a5 the rook takes a4 uh
pardon me knight rook takes f4 knight
takes a4 and we have this four versus
three
with the knights on the board also this
very important move f5 comes in the
position destabilizes black structure on
the king side also gets rid of my double
pawn
very very important move f5 and now we
have this position on the board e4 f6
and to be honest right now i'm really
liking wise chances to potentially take
the full point in this one i'm going to
go knight to e3 knight to d5 then i'm
going to slowly start squeezing you with
the move f4 f5 h4 get gain more and more
uh space on this side the material is
still quite reduced so black definitely
still has chances to potentially uh save
this position but it's not going to be
easy alejandro no it's suffering for a
while i do feel
objectively this is closer to a draw
than to a wind just because there's not
enough amount of material but that being
said this is going to be quite the
torture there's a lot of ways to squeeze
black from here
making that draw is difficult
and it will take quite a while let's
finish up the games in group b just so
that we see what's going on there
in the game of your student of roger
harshit here playing against titus
tramavichus it's pretty one-sided you
can see that this rook on c5
it's just a better piece than the rook
on d6 there's a pair of bishops this
bishop is threading the pawn on d5 and
similar to the game of jj ali miranda
it's just really a question of whether
black can survive this
it's hard for me to say
just by looking at it
it feels like the position is very
locked that it's difficult to make
progress but white has so much space
white has so many targets while it does
have the pair of bishops i feel that
this will be at least torture for a very
long time so we're going to leave it
alone i'm being told that just to finish
up group b a lot of action did happen in
the game between armand mikhailian
and
elsa maria de abadi i'm just going to
start from here
because
i don't want to spend time on the entire
game but
this is a mess
both sides are
somehow attacking materials even this
bishop is pretty nice this knight is
pretty bad but it is holding on to an
important position it's a good defensive
piece and this is a good defensive piece
right you have two uh rooks there you
start to have to consider as black what
happens if rook g7 and queen g4 the
attack is nothing to be shrugged at but
still perhaps no decisive threats and
precisely because of that black decided
to think i'm going to invade on the
queen side and start creating my own
threats via the first rank so we have a
very double edged position here white
going on the king side with a frontal
assault black going on the king side
more with a side assault on the first
rank d5 was played which is a
fascinating move trying to open up the
position trying to play e6 joining the
fair with more moves but some things
happen queen c1 threatens checkmate on
g1 so you have to do something about it
rookie 3 is very logical the move queen
g1 actually doesn't do very much yes the
king is not super happy about being on
g1 on the other hand kind of hard to
reach it
and in the game instead it seems like
elsian played the move h5 at the
beginning this looks like a very clever
move in the sense that the rook doesn't
have actually a lot of good squares
now let me explain that for example if
the root goes to f4 or something along
those
lines uh then of course after pawn takes
d5 you don't have the same kind of
threat
on
on the g7 squares and in many cases
these rooks are actually pretty awkward
one of those cases is for example when
you play e6 and i take on e6 you would
have liked to immediately take on e6
here back and then your pieces start
coordinating this is kind of the point
of d5 break but in this particular
position
if you take on e6 queen takes f4 is
check and that wins the game so you
start to notice that surprisingly most
of the rook moves here have some kind of
problem or another for example the rook
on d4 means that this pawn is no longer
creating any kind of threats so it's
immediately pinned and rook g3 just got
made it in one unfortunately for el shen
i could just ignore it i can take on
e6 i believe precisely yeah yeah again
queen g1 doesn't do that much and if we
trade rooks
the problem is that the remaining
threats with e6 are actually quite
strong it's not easy to see this from
far away no it's visually appealing
black's position is visually appealing
in my opinion because you have those two
checks queen to g1 or queen to h1 also
you have potentially ideas of g3 of
course after g3 you're not going to take
back with the rook because that's going
to lead to a checkmate on g1 or h1
you're going to take back with the king
and it seems like white's king is in
danger but it's actually the reverse
black's king in this position is in huge
danger for example if you take back on
e6 whatever you take with
i'm not going to take with a bishop
giving up a check i'm going to take with
the rook because i want to preserve that
important bishop attacking peace on c4
it's very important to keep as many
attacking pieces as possible right now
of course that knight cannot be taken
for various reasons rook takes e8 is a
huge threat but also if you put the
queen on c3 i can just drop back with
the rook that's going to be a discovery
check and your queen is going to be lost
so it seems like after rook takes e6 i'm
trying to understand what did black
calculate what did elchen see in this
position that he felt okay i'm safe to
do this i'm sure to allow all of white
species to invade like this maybe
exactly the line that you are showing
right now alejandro
king to h7 and i think this is what he
missed this bishop to d3 move
maybe although i think once you see
rookie sex you feel you're kind of lost
or maybe he also felt that potentially
queen to f4 might come after rook takes
e6
ah maybe let's put that position again
so you take on e6 i take on g4 you take
on d7
uh i kind of have to
and then you take you take and you hope
for queen for chuck but unfortunately
and i think within his calculation maybe
he forgot that his bishop moves from c6
to d7 that's a huge deal and now after
g3 you no longer have rook to h1
checkmate yeah that's a big big big big
big big big deal in the position but
it seems and we have some moves we don't
have the move it takes uh d takes e6 we
have over d4 both players missed it
which seems to be
not ideal queen g1 king g3 is the
current position
and we might have a wild one in our
hands christian i don't even know how to
begin evaluating this black white
surprisingly doesn't have any real
threats right because if you take on e6
or you take on c6 d4 is hanging
that being said all right alejandra i'm
going to test you all right find a good
move for black oh my gosh i'm not going
to i'm not going to get this one right
am i
[Music]
if he finds it black is probably going
to be winning this game winning this
game absolutely i have a feeling it's g6
once you see it it makes a lot of sense
i like the move g6 and what is your idea
knight g7 and knight f5 great idea okay
the better execution is to go g5
ah
oh okay once you see it yeah once you
see it actually g5 is very promising
right h4 is a big threat yeah h4 is a
big threat but also this idea of knight
g7 is a very potent idea very potent
maneuver by the knight
in uh including your final piece into
the attack one of the most important
pieces into your attack and you were
mentioning you hated that night yeah
yeah it was defensive piece now is going
to transition into a tremendous
attacking piece
oh this turns the tables around
completely and g5 of course immediately
thrown into the movie h4 so that
actually does require some kind of
thought i mean i'm assuming h4 king g4
is not that playable
um no big moment this is a big moment
yeah it's a big moment for that game
elshen i saw
i saw that the way elsian went for it
for something and he feels that he's
better i mean i've played and saw and
seen elsian play so much chess
throughout the years you kind of know
through his body language when he feels
he has something and he's just kind of
double checking i wonder can i show you
why uh g5 and not g6 yeah go ahead
christian thank you so now if you go
first of all if you go uh g5
white no longer has this move d takes e6
because i'm not going to take this rook
on d4 but rather i'm going to give you a
check first
and after king to g4 this rook is going
to fall with a check leading to a
completely winning position for a black
white doesn't have this extra tempo to
take on f7 and create havoc in black's
position so
after
g5 of course after h4 the only move
would be rook takes h4 but that's just a
simple win we're not going to look at
that so
after g5
things are very shaky uh for white it
seems like there's absolutely no move to
uh break through uh towards black's
position and the only way to get out of
this is to try to exchange the queens
with queen to f2 which leads to a much
better position after just the simple he
takes a d5 it seems like
after you take with something on d5 all
of your pieces are going to be tied up
you cannot take with the bishop this is
key because after rook to f1 well that's
just resign on the spot and if you have
to take with a different piece
then um
then the bishop then i can just simply
continue taking and once again force you
to take with the bishop followed by rook
to f1 this position right now is
dominating for black el shawn as you
were mentioning it seems like from his
body language knows it we're going to
have to wait and see if he manages to
pull through and win this one yeah we'll
come back to him certainly a promising
position here for el shen let's go to
group a we haven't seen a lot of those
games just a little quick update on
where everybody is standing uh sam
savion against dario sphere it's a
little bit of a dry position you can see
that uh
sam had just played the move knight b5 i
think it forces black to capture this
knight on b5 it is still a little bit
too annoying uh queen takes f5 would
follow knight g5 is a devastating threat
but after the move h6 i really don't see
what's wrong with black's position the
knight can come back to d6 where it will
be very nicely blocking the pawn on d5
i'm not really sure that black is better
either white does have a lot of space
i feel this is very close to equality
between sam and daryush meanwhile in the
game of collegiate chess aram jacobian
against misha antipov i have to prefer
white's position here by quite a bit
especially if this knight ends up
landing on c4 which i don't know how to
avoid
after which this pawn on a5 causes a
much
cleaner impression than this pawn on c5
that's already blockaded this bishop on
d2 certainly better than the bishop on
c7 it takes a tremendous amount of
technical task to actually push this
pawn on a5 forward but if you were to
pick a side i don't think it's even
close white is certainly in the driver's
seat in this position christian you
agree no absolutely yes yes yes the
computer is saying that the position is
very close to equality but from a
practical perspective this definitely
doesn't feel like it because as you were
mentioning this pawn is so strong yeah
it requires uh for black so many
resources right this rook on a7 the
zircon b5 always keeping an eye on that
now you don't want to hurry with knight
take c4 because this allows me uh to get
into the game with some tactics after
knight to b6 that's a nice move if i
manage to exchange the knight then i'm
very happy yeah if i manage to exchange
tonight then i'm uh getting closer and
closer to equality instead of that
you're not going to hurry taking on c4
you're actually going to look at the
position and ask yourself what is
black's next move and that is to go f5
try to put some pressure in at the
center potentially dislocate this knife
from e3 via f4 so the best move in the
position for white would be to go g4 and
just play a slow game i'm going to
reinforce uh the defense of this pawn on
a5 with rook to a1 also of the rook on
a4 and that's not going to allow this
idea of knight to b6 in the future so
i'm going to go rook to a1 knight takes
c4 and it does seem at least from a
practical perspective once again that um
white's position is to be preferred and
it's very important to look also at the
clock situation
right now we have
15 moves to make for antipov he only has
10 minutes on the clock that's not a lot
of time that's going to go down to your
final minute just like that and then
you're going to have to find some saving
race uh because you you don't know what
white is going to do potentially rook to
a1 g4 maybe even bring the king all the
way to c3 i have a lot of uh preparatory
moves as white you don't have a clear
way to just simply wait in this position
and this is a big problem
yes a little bit of issues there around
who's simply shown great chess
throughout the tournament very well
prepared and playing cleanly beating
jeffrey yesterday with the black piece
is certainly a big milestone in his
career speaking of jeffrey himself it's
him that's playing with the black pieces
he is on the defensive side of a pawn
ending i'm against ray robson and there
is nothing scarier to me than pawn end
games because they are all either one
lost or drawn and one move can destroy
the evaluation remember there is no such
thing as slightly better in pawn engines
you can actually calculate them all out
mathematically and that's why they're so
difficult and that's why they're so
difficult because one little mistake and
that mathematics goes out the window but
since i don't have an hour to spend here
and analyzing myself i'm gonna guess my
instinct says this is a draw of course
white is the one that is pushing here
for the win and i'm gonna explain why he
has more space and he has more
opportunities for this king to quickly
penetrate and try to create havoc on the
pawns but that being said there's not a
lot of avenues to attack uh the white
the pawns the king is going to try to
stay between c6 and d6 this pawn is
going to try to clamp down on a5 i
believe
but i don't think this is quite enough
to win it just is not it is not yeah i'm
not surprised no i'm just simply going
to go b6 taking away that c5 square from
your king and uh you're not going to be
able to push me around whenever you go
a5 i'm just going to wait i'm going to
go king to c6 yeah and you'd never take
right no you would love to have the move
b5 yeah b5 and i take on b5 and just
imagine uh the king being on b4 and me
being able to go a6 that would be a win
for white
yeah but unfortunately whenever you play
b5 i'm taking back on b5 with a check
yeah that's a problem yeah it just seems
like resources for white are not that
great actually pontex a5 is an important
source of counter play because i'm i am
kind of forcing white to take on b6 at
some point i can't just lose time with
my king i don't have enough moves on the
king side to just get rid of my tempe
yeah this one looks like it should be a
draw it feels like jeffrey calculated
precisely yeah it feels like jeffrey
yeah i mean somehow they simplified
from here yeah okay if you don't get
into the pawn again white's not going to
have anything the pawn again does look a
little scary but
but i'm sure that jeffrey has this under
control we expect the draw as the first
result of the day then between these two
players
iliya nizhnik against camille dragoon
really sometimes when you look at these
positions and you ask how to evaluate
them it's very simple one side has space
the other one does not have space
therefore white is better
everything else pretty much equal but
these pawns on the center are doing a
magnificent job of keeping black's
pieces at bay rooks are just totally
passive the queen is totally passive the
knight doesn't have any good squares and
white's pieces can just jump around the
board whenever they want i can take on
b6 whenever i want i can play rook a1
whenever i want and i also like this
idea of knight e3 knight f5 i can play
93 95 if i felt like it i don't know
where my knight is strongest white has
an infinite amount of tempe
to improve his position
it's basically clay in his hands at this
moment to maneuver around and figure out
when he wants to make that final push of
final breakthrough and black is uh just
absolutely passive for the rest of the
game no activity whatsoever you could
even put the queen on h3 it's not
helping it does not participate with the
other pieces
uh i would say ilya
i would give this a decisive advantage
for white i'm sure that there is some
way to maneuver your pieces properly and
for black not to have an appropriate
reaction back and this center is just
too strong right it even almost feels
that white has more pawns than black
that's actually not the case they're
actually equal material but the
the superiority on the center is just
overwhelming well black only has one way
to get out of this position and that is
to play f5 yeah and try to break in the
center like that that's why i want to
play knight to e3 and first solidify
that control over the f5 square and then
re-maneuver my pieces on the a-file and
b6 or k-1 or k-7 and so on absolutely
agree with you christian when you look
at this position with the black pieces
you think how do i get out of a bind the
most common way to get out of a bind in
this kind of situation is you want to
create a pawn break you want to create
that tension you want to make sure that
the pawns disappear and your pieces
start getting some breathing room so for
that reason the move 93 f5
preventing that only break that black
has jumps to mind very quickly that
being said all of that's being true the
move f5 is actually very sad
because even if you get that move in
pawn on e5 is isolated and in some cases
it will actually just
hasten black's demise so certainly a
tough position here for the polish
player
and i think last but certainly not least
okay maybe at least we have this game
between hans demon and alex lander
nothing to do with the players but more
to do with the position it is a little
bit on the dry side
white has a pair of bishops a little bit
more space it is an exchange slav maybe
white has some clear chances because if
i have okay but b4 is a very important
move yeah i think so too if you play any
other move so let's just play something
like king d8 right
now after a4 i think you're quite in uh
some trouble because if you take on a4
obviously that's going to allow me to
create a new weakness the pawn on a6
activate my bishop on d3 and this is
going to be uh quite a difficult defense
for black if you go b4 well you still
have uh that weakness on b4 after this
move a5 very important move creating uh
basically activating both of my bishops
at the same time
yeah and i think alex is a strong player
that is very used to send to exchange
slots he actually placed it both with
white and with black he is one of those
players that enjoys this symmetrical
structures very much
i actually played it with the black side
against him in the u.s chess
championship so i know how clever he can
be in this kind of situations uh but he
spots this problem puts upon him before
the spot is probably not going to stay
on a6 for very long we'll probably go
all the way back down to a5
and
i agree with you christian obviously i
would take black sorry i would take
white you have the pair of bishops and
more space but
i don't put uh hans's chances of
converting this one uh
too high of a point alejandro we have
breaking news in this position oh my
elshon did find the move g5 good stuff
he found it and now he's uh in the
driver's seat as white you've been
attacking black's position for so many
moves right now you're on defensive end
and queen to f2 is a very difficult
practical decision difficult move to
make you're still losing even after that
um at least objectively but perhaps
bitcoin to f2 gives you the best chances
in the position nevertheless i don't see
this as an easy move to make i think
white is going to try for a very long
time he only has 11 minutes on the clock
right now to find something to break
through and uh potentially win this game
and get the black king unfortunately
there's no such thing in the position
and this knight g7 knight to f5 is
coming with devastating consequences
after g5 black is in the driver's seat
and it seems like uh maybe el shan is
going to bounce back with a victory
today yeah very nice from al-sham there
with the move g5 topsy-turvy game for
sure
oh he loves playing that move g5 look at
it look at him yeah yeah he's so proud
of that look at that air confidence
right but it's a nice move to play right
you play g5 and you know yeah that was a
good move it's an amazing move to play
yeah yeah and the pressure that you put
on your opponent the king the the clock
ticking the knight coming to f5 you can
see it look at that little stereo just
gave us a point i mean i mean that's
such an thing to do
uh it looks bad for white let's see if
he's able to survive
one game that's going from a bad to
worse alejandro is the clash the one
that we were having our eyes on as the
main game in the big group the one
between uh the rating favorite robert
hungaski and the leader in the event
with three out of three points chris
rapko and this one is not going anywhere
for white in this position he played the
move queen to a3 queen to d1 b6 just
simply making more space for the bishop
on ca to potentially join the fray via
the queen side via the square a6
and uh at this point he decided to go f5
try to create something on the king's
side try to get to uh the black king
nevertheless as i was mentioning this f5
allows this bishop on e7 that was uh
let's say a bit passive for the moment
activate via g5 with devastating
consequences once again bishop to g5
came on the board queen takes g4 you
equalize the pawns but unfortunately
your position collapses because all of
my pieces are going to invade and that's
going to be all she rose he played a
queen to b2 king to h3 and now we have
rook to c2 on the board bishop to a6 to
follow bishop to f1 bishop to e2
this is not looking good
this is looking very very bad right now
four minutes and 30 seconds and counting
five moves to make but to be honest
after queen to f3 bishop to a6
instantaneously played the computer just
well
it's so bad that the computer right now
wants to take on d5 and just simply give
the rook for absolutely nothing
resignable at this point yeah it's not
going to happen what happens to rook d1
just by the way
i think it's the only human movement
rook to d1 i'm just simply going to go
rook to c3 yeah this looks terrible and
if you take
queen to f2 yeah you just can't defend
the knight right no you're going to give
a check i'm going to go to h7 and that's
uh the end of your attack you're not
even going to take my the queen huh
yeah no queen you have one check and
once again i go here and that's it
uh this one is yeah
it's done after bishop to a6 maybe he's
going to go rook to uh d1 i'm sure chris
already knows this he's been playing
quite quickly the last few moves he uh
calculated all of this is not very
difficult to calculate you have so many
attackers white doesn't have enough
defenders and this position is about to
collapse for robert hungaski and that's
going to allow chris repcot to move on
to four out of four in such a strong
field
what's your opinion on that
i have the feeling that i could have
subbed them in for another slew recruit
huh no i'm just kidding i love my
recruits chris repko with a very
convincing play and you see already the
moves rook d1 rook c3 on the board we
expect the move queen f2 i wanted to
check this game of l-sham very very
quickly because we had very quick
updates g5 knight e4 was played by some
and instantly came the move knight g7
not even a thought over about about this
one
it i find it interesting that this was
played instantly in this movie knight g7
but if it's good it's good
it does throw knight f5
knight f6 check and instantly again the
move king f8
um knight f5 is on tap you don't care
about knight 87 i guess i'll just take
it back with the bishop
and it's not so much about the exchange
anymore but about the power of these
pieces
and this king on g3 being
totally stranded on the wrong side of
the board and
yeah this looks this looks winning to me
i think that move knight f5 is just too
difficult to deal with
no absolutely and this knight to g7 king
to f8 it's obvious that el shawn uh from
afar calculated this whole variation
and he uh calculated with decisive
precision because after you take on d7
bishop takes d7 and you try to do
something like bishop to d3 it looks
like the only move that defends against
knight to f5 right you would love to
play rook to f3 and sacrifice that rook
the problem is there's another hook on
the board which is unprotected the rook
on d4 i can just simply uh uh
take that off the board so after bishop
to d3 now this is what i'm going to
start looking at your queen is defending
too many weak spots one of them is g2
another one is e3 so what i'm going to
do i'm going to attack that queen i'm
going to play rook to a2
which finishes the game yeah the problem
is that if you take on a2 queen e3 check
as mentioned before this rook on d4 is
always hanging
and you're not losing one rook you're
using two rooks yeah this is too much
yeah that's just game over right yeah
yeah this looks like elson is cruising
for a victory here against arma
michaelian
very nice attacking game i think he's uh
he's giving his himself a little bit of
a relax already calculating the critical
variations and it's the black pieces
that are coming together here in group b
chris repka uh the verge of victory so
is al-sham muradi and we were thinking
abhimanyu mishra is also
i think maybe we should uh watch
that game closely the one between
hungaski and chris repko because i think
we're going to see a handshake very soon
after bishop bishop to e2 just finished
forces resignation
that that is a big fork and there it is
bishop e2 on the board
and we expect uh we can maybe see them
on camera
uh yep and there is a resignation yeah
and that's four out of four for chris
repka
playing like a beast absolutely
good stuff there from the youngster from
university of missouri
all right let's continue uh we're
talking about the game between abimenya
mishra and khan in
um kanin
i still like black a lot in this
position i mean this knight on b4 is
really good bishop on b1 seems a bit
passive considering uh the structure on
the king side the bishop on c6 is nice
these pawns feel like big weaknesses and
of course black has a very nice control
over the open file is this a decisive
advantage
i would probably not i'm probably not i
wouldn't really say that but it's
looking good it's looking really nice i
mean you you take a look at the the
wait a minute wait a minute
my spidey senses are tingling like i
would say they don't work right if i
take on f3 so what we're worried about
is that we see a queen on c7 we see some
pressure on e1 and we're wondering if
there's a background checkmate somewhere
but
okay so let's go on with the variation
after bishop takes f3 and here you have
to take on uh e5 there's no choice queen
takes e5 queen takes f3
yeah and now the question is is there
something like queen b2 b2 rook to d1
and maybe that's not enough right maybe
there's no real way to put any pressure
right
no it doesn't seem like it feels like
i'm unnecessarily simplifying this
position
yeah once the bishop comes to e4 it's
not not that good you know so the bishop
dreams of landing on d5
this one yeah the light square white
bishop yes okay
dreams of landing on d5 unfortunately
it's a very difficult road
to that square
there's other moves we can play i'm
actually wondering if i should just
trade everybody sure
you take the rook i think
you take here i take here and i go
and the reason i'm doing it right now in
this move order is that this queen is
actually very badly placed it actually
has a very sad job
uh you don't really want to be defending
pawns with your most powerful piece
right the queen on b3 would like to be
out there free playing around giving
checks but it's tethered to this part on
a4 this weakness on a4 it doesn't have
the capacity to defend this knight on e
on e1 so easily either you can't
exchange the quiz this is what i would
normally like to play but as we
mentioned uh you the spawn falls and the
same game looks hopeless
so it actually asked a very pertinent
question here on how you develop right
you could go
um knight f3 but you're not because yeah
three i'll take with the pawn the point
of course is i can take take queen e1
picks up a bishop it's a double attack
but i will take with the pawn so the
queen remains defending but
there's so many weaknesses it's such an
ugly i mean
literally every single one of white's
pawns is a weakness every
single one of them is undefensible
indefensible by another pawn they have
to be protected by pieces but maybe
that's not the best way to do it right
it might not be the best one to do it
but it is tempting enough for me to
start considering these things i agree
yeah and you play at the resultant game
and and i think he is going for it
because he has started with the move
knight rook takes c1 uh rook takes e1 is
currently on the board
um
i expect him to take again on e1
yes and he has rook takes c1 knight
takes e1
and i'll remind you playing
very good chess today
playing for the win in this game and
here perhaps there's a couple of
different options because queen e5 is
one way but queen d7 may be just being
greedy
maybe greed is good just attack
this weakness directly
and ask quite how he's going to defend
it because i have actually no answer to
that
that's uh i mean a very good question
another good question
sometimes easy questions are the hardest
questions and this one um
this one is an easy question to point
but i don't see an easy answer to the
fact okay okay okay i have an idea so
what if i just simply go bishop to c2
yeah i understand
if i take i will take it with the knight
you'll take with the knight and i don't
even want to think about it but i was
actually wondering what you play after
queen d2
and this one i didn't figure out
that's another good question that's
another i keep asking good to go king to
f1 yeah you have to go king of one to
defend this guy but here i even have
this move
yeah no this looking and this is a
distraction tactic if you take with the
king queen takes e1 if you take with the
knight queen takes c2 and in either
either scenario it just seems like a
hopeless end game that bishop on c2
right the light square bishop is such a
terrible piece it's a terrible piece i
think windy 7 is the correct move
uh but i wouldn't be surprised there's
other
there
looks decisive and and this is what you
should be looking at yeah in this
position how to attack the weakness and
it's not even the only way right we can
even consider going like queen here
knight f3 and not going for any of those
stuff just go queen a1
attacking the weakness attacking the
weakness right this way right right
and also bishop to e4 right now is a big
threat so you have to probably go king
to h2 but bishop a4 actually wins the
four
yeah it actually doesn't win a pawn
right it wins a piece oh yeah that's the
problem
sad situation that's the problem because
let me put this on the board king h2 we
should take a four and the queen doesn't
actually have a good square to defend
this bishop from so you actually have to
give up you could go to e3 and i'm happy
that potentially you're going to give a
perpetual and then the surprise is that
that bishop a4 is just defending eight
yeah yeah
no that i think it's just game over
queen you five queen anyone i think is
game over looks like it yeah abby mind
you going uh has he won a game yet i
don't think so he just won a game
yesterday yesterday that's right raja
harshit so so yeah he might be going for
back-to-back victories good for him
that's an excellent recovery of course
we are all very interested in what this
great talent is going to be bringing to
the chess world
as he's contemplating his options over
there we have a couple of results as we
expected ray robson and jeffrey shaun
have split that point um
chris replica has won that game
let's take a look at maybe some
developments on the a group nothing
major in the darius game
this looks
like
this is the game between hakobian and
antipov
and certainly you still prefer white in
this position i think the knight is a
little bit more powerful
than the bishop but
is this really enough
i don't think so and actually i'm
wondering if i can play the move rook c7
i just spotted that
i think you can okay i think i can and
after rook c7 i don't believe
antipov has any sort of problem so this
is
yeah that seems like the easiest
and this just seems like it's going to
finish in a draw but i gave it the not
finish in a draw is a man that has four
out of four and is setting the
tournament on fire it is chris redka
here with his coach christian carrillo
thank you alejandro yes we are here with
a very happy victor of the round uh
chris four out of four such a dominant
display in the first part of this event
how does that feel yeah yeah i don't
know what's going on i didn't expect
this even today
um
i i really don't know how to describe
what i'm feeling right now it's one of
the best moments of my career
well i'm going to quiz you do you know
who else started this tournament with
five out of five three years ago
um
no idea your coach i did all right i
started with five out of five so that's
your uh quest for tomorrow
uh chris take us through the game
all right
i even forgot right now what the opening
was
okay french
so now i can
my coach christian is always telling me
that i shouldn't play french so i'm
really really happy
that i want this one
this is a tricky line this is uh this is
new and um i feel like there's a lot of
options for both sides
and i
am i was really happy because i picked
the option that i think my opponent
wasn't prepared for because
after h5 the typical response is h6
but i knew that knight f5 is also one of
the options
but everyone usually plays h6
so i chose to play knight f5 i was
hoping i would get him out of prep and i
think i did because he was thinking here
for 10 minutes he played the right move
bishop f5 is a good move but now i think
white is supposed to play h6
um
and after g takes h6 cd4 if i'm not
mistaken
and
it's some kind of a bishop e6 knight c3
game
it's
crazy but
white is slightly better but i was i i
thought that it looks visib
it looks like black is better in the
position because i have the g file i
have the attack and if he doesn't know
uh the line then for sure he's not gonna
go for it because i wouldn't go for it
with white and that's exactly what
happened
it's good logic
so he took on f5 he did not play the
move h6 he played
knight to c3
and uh i feel like
this bishop to g5 was a very crafty move
were you surprised by his response f4
i was because i think i was looking at
it and you know knight e192 usually
those are the types of moves that lose
you the game but not in the french in
french they often win white the games
straight out of the opening so i was a
bit worried i knew that i'm probably
objectively fine after castling but i
was really worried
about rook g3 and g3 was giving uh quite
the advantage after bishop g5 or before
uh now in this one now so i was worried
and i knew that bishop g5 is probably
not the best but i really didn't want to
be under such an attack even even if
this is objectively good for black i
don't like it because h6 is hanging and
that's why i played bishop g5 and i was
very happy i didn't play rook g3 because
i felt like that's a
that's a good move
my idea was to play bishop c1 and rook
c1 and castle and even though i'm
strategically worse here than i was
before i felt like he'll at least not
mate me and it's a game
um
queen d2 maybe and maybe i have to play
something like king h8
but i thought that this is okay still a
very long game
i thought that i'm okay but
maybe i'm not maybe white is just better
i don't know
all right but f4 happened and
where did the big mistake from him come
i think f4 was a big mistake because now
he has no attack and uh his position
doesn't make sense his last couple of
moves 91 92 don't make sense
in this setup
i agree with that
and after that it felt like a slow build
up for you to just uh optimize your
pieces
and he was really looking for that
breakthrough which never came well it
came but unfortunately at great cost i
think he was supposed to play knight g3
instead of g4 and
i think the position is very interesting
maybe queen a6 is a small mistake
now f5 is hanging but
even if he takes on f5 i usually have a
counter play with queen f1 what was your
uh
move what was your prepared move at this
point after knight g2 i actually wasn't
so sure so i always have the option to
play g6 but that looks terrible so
i was thinking about bishop of eight but
that might be losing i i don't know
knight f5 queen f1 i was i was gonna
calculate this
i didn't know what's going on
i mean i'm certainly not losing my
pieces are active and it doesn't seem
like i'm getting made it
but interesting sacrifice
and he decided to go g4 were you
surprised by this movie very surprised i
think uh i'm a bit fortunate in the last
few rounds that it seems like my
opponents are really trying to beat me
even when they could play without like
this is a very risky move
my opponents are always choosing to play
these risky variations
and i definitely felt like g4 shouldn't
be possible his pieces are on e1 and e2
and his bishop on c3 is not doing much
so i didn't really
think that g4 could work
and indeed it didn't it felt that the
build up actually only helped the black
especially after he gave up that bishop
on c3 and then you just kind of cleanly
cruise to victory of course this seems
already quite hopeless for your opponent
chris congratulations a dominant victory
a dominant display up to this point well
good luck in the rest of your games
thank you
well certainly a great start there for
chris rapko with four out of four
congratulations to him let's take a look
at what else is happening in today's
round let's take a look at else mario de
bodies game we were definitely
interested in that one
um let's take a look at what's happened
we did leave it off here after check on
f6 king f8
bishop d3 prevents the move knight f5
but
rook takes d5 actually this one is
catching me a bit of surprise
we expected the move rook a2 in
different variations
and i think rookie 2 is kind of crushing
here right i don't actually see the
difference
between this position and other
positions is this what he played he
played rook d5 i played rook takes d5
yeah no no um definitely a2 i think was
just killing you're killing right
this still looks pretty good
but um
well it's c5
actually can we go back i'm just a
second confused about things can you
just go back um
so rook a2 yeah rookie two looks let's
see just winning because you do have
that knight on f6 and maybe you will
have some sort of a checkmate coming so
queen takes a two you take one rook on
e3 then you take my second rook on e3
but actually you take on e5 i always
take on e5 first right so the king goes
everything first you can even take the
knight takes like you're taking the
knight if i've actually taken the knight
just much cleaner right
yeah yeah um
i mean just collapses i'm still hitting
this there's no checks i mean there's a
check on a3 but who cares
and
yeah this is just collapsed right well
he chose a different way right so he
took on d5 with the rope we have rook
takes d5 bishop takes d5 queen d2
c5
i just feel that if i had to play c5 c5
is already a bit scary right because
queen b4 was checkmate and
i get it c5 might be winning but
i'm not super happy about it
check
i assume you have to go to g8 or e7 all
right
why not easy yeah you can go through
seven h37 looks much better
this knight on h7 looks silly after that
king e7 and it feels like the same idea
applies right king to e7i takes g5 now
once again rk2 is going to come on the
board yeah if you take on g5 then rk2
again it's this ugly fork that you get
with the queen on e3 later on the game
because this attacks the knight and if
you push forward i'm assuming that first
of all i could take the bishop but i'm
looking to see if queen f4 leads to
checkmate i actually don't see the
checkmate so probably i take the bishop
is this true there's no checkmate after
queen f4 yeah let's just well
queen wait wait wait wait wait go back
yeah
unfortunately i don't have that i was uh
thinking about queen to e1
yeah but then g3 right g3 yeah yeah g3
and now queen to b4 and if you play g4
then yes queen to e1 is checkmate but
you can just simply play bishop c4
yeah
so no i'm just going to pick up your
just pick up the bishop
i mean there's no reason to make your
life hard yeah you have queen a7 at the
end
um so perhaps not the end of the
variation
okay maybe this is not that easy it's
not that easy at all huh
[Music]
all right alejandro let's put our gm
hats on
yeah let's not be so lazy right and try
to find what is my actual win instead of
rookie two maybe there's something
better erica looks pretty good though it
does but what if i try to force things
with
maybe not
um maybe
i mean i could attack the queen also
yeah rook d1 i was thinking about that i
did not like queen to f2 after queen to
f to h4 h4 yeah game is over okay yeah
but if you play with z1 you have to play
to e2 right but now i can take on d3
and knight to f5 and then knight f5 is
that must be a checkmate it has to be
checkmate somehow yeah that must be a
checkmate okay in the worst case i can
go queen to h2 which forces g3 and i
pick up your queen that's pretty good
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with that's
pretty that's pretty good yeah picking
up a free queen pretty good all right uh
he has instead played the move rookie 2
perhaps because of these variations
uh rookie 2 was played so king d7 was on
the board yeah king 7 on the board
rookie 2 has been played
rook d1 looks like checkmate to me well
i do have queen takes g5 oh i apologize
i am blind today
so maybe you have to start with
something else
ah what if
what if i go
h4
i have to go up there's the only legal
move so
i follow up with queen d4 and then just
simply pick up the pawn
where is the checkmate uh the king must
run yeah i can go up to h5 even no no
there's a knight that's an item yeah
okay king takes g5
and this is a good question
that is a great question where's my mate
i feel i should be able to slow roll
this somehow but i don't see it like
rook f1
it's not like white has any threats
right no so i could play rook f1 you
could but then i actually go king h6
oh my god what is going on i'm starting
to threaten some some checks you're
throwing my knight and your knight
okay i'm sorry do likewise position
okay let's not get carried away
all right where's the mate here rookie
two is a clever move because it allows
the screen g5 stuff let's find it
let's find it
so point to g5 is a big problem
all right
hmm
man i don't see i don't see it either
right it's not so obvious
i mean it could be a move
like king somewhere but i don't really
want to make a move like king somewhere
so there was another option but that
didn't make any sense
why is it so hard there's a king on g3
on my king or my pieces are attacking
there should be a killing blow here
yeah
where is it where is it though maybe
maybe a move like
king to
d7 or something like
yeah king uh
king uh king d7 could be it
huh this is actually not easy not as
easy as i thought it would be i still
feel like there's a win here somewhere
though
well they might be here all day
yeah he's making his life more difficult
than it should happen that's the thing
that happens right sometimes you make
your life difficult just before time
control and then you panic so strange
this is very strange he had so many easy
wins so he has 10 more minutes right no
never mind he has three minutes yes
that's what worries me
that's what really worries me by the way
i peeked at the engine yeah it's not
winning anymore no way it's not winning
anymore no way this is not winning
anymore no and you know what the best
move is
queen to c1
good luck
with the king on g well wait wait wait
wait wait he played he played h4 he
played h4
even worse
now it's only
a
middle of an edge really
queen to d4 i keep going up oh my god
and then rook f1
yeah he's always king king h6 actually
playable
he did play queen to d4 so we're
probably going to see this uh landing on
g5
crazy stuff there between
armon and el shawn absolutely insane
we're going to leave that one for a
little bit because we do have a guest
winner here in round number four ilya
nishnik one of the strongest players of
the area has defeated camille dragoon
ilya how does it feel
uh pretty good finally i won a winning
position he was great
it started off in round number one
against sam savion you were on the back
foot at the beginning but after that you
came back and it ended up in a draw and
uh after that you had another very
pleasant edge against lenderman i think
right uh well no in the first game i
believe i was i was in a little bit of a
trouble after the opening and i don't
think sam was ever in trouble the game
number two was what uh what i'm still
kind of uh hating myself for it was a
just a completely winning position where
i had an extra rook and and then yeah
just hunts against hans yeah against
hans neiman and uh
what happened in the escape on his side
exactly yeah
he he he mentioned uh his uh his um the
game where he escaped down the queen but
it was a very similar pawn structure
there was there was this game queen
versus knight exactly i believe he
played in um and he won he not only
won that yeah exactly exactly so uh hans
has experienced playing dumb material
and as he as he claimed after the game
he's really good with knights so well
we're not in the past right now you won
a beautiful game today how does that
feel uh it was it was actually yeah it
came came down to be a very interesting
game my opponent surprised me was his
opening choice to go for a sideline in
english move number number two bishop b4
is what my opponent played and i was
honestly not prepared
um
let's look at that trying to remember my
analysis
uh couldn't do it
played what seemed to be logical moves
and somehow it worked out so yeah i
believe the critical point of the game
is if you go back a couple more moves
before
my opponent wanted to play c5 i believe
that that probably uh camille did not or
probably he either did not cc5 or
greatly underestimated the idea and um
he can actually play bishop h3 whenever
he wants and that's the point so if if
he just wants to play bishop h3 which i
agree should be his main plan here
because i have a bishop her advantage so
trading bishops by playing bishop h3
does make sense however allowing c5 is
is is
not exactly uh
the way to go in my mind so if if i ever
him instead of playing bishop h3
immediately i would have played b6
so just
stopping c5
and the problem the problem here with my
position is that i have a very nice
looking center but those pawns never
never get to move anywhere so i can't
play d4 right now
and um hey because the pawn on c4 is
hanging and if my opponent plays bishop
h3 that would be let's see let's see if
i make a make a random good looking move
such as
i'm not sure if that's a good looking
move but how about the queen e2
now if my opponent plays bishop h3 takes
takes
yeah it takes takes and here i can try
to play d4 but now after i go d4 i
immediately get an issue with the c4
pawn so i believe that my opponent's
play here will be based upon
putting a lot of pressure against a c4
pawn by playing maybe knight a5 going
back queen e6 and i wasn't sure what's
going to happen i believe that i would i
would have probably had to
do this if i wanted to win but yeah i
was
i was hesitant
fortunately for me uh uh yeah camille
camille missed on the c5id and now my
play is just extremely straightforward
and we do see a result that we had
expected avi manu mishra has defeated
his opponent that makes it two in a row
for the youngster
to in a row after uh did he lose two the
first no he
he lost one he lost one against jj and
he drew this uh the first one and i
think he drew the first game yes that is
true
so back to the game uh where did you
feel was the decisive mistake after that
or was it just a slow build i i honestly
i felt like it just went downhill for
criminal from this point on he's he
started spending time and he he suddenly
he realized how unpleasant this idea is
yeah because probably queen d7 was or
might have been
a slight an accuracy although i honestly
do not really know what what else
because the d5 is coming and i don't
think black ever wants to take on c5
because
i would i'm not even sure if i would
have taken the pawn back because
yeah like yeah exactly so instead of
queen d7 if you can go back one movie
yeah so if black takes in c5 right now i
was planning to play d5
and uh and i just have so much pressure
and all these central points is what
what gives me so much space uh combined
with a very powerful bishop on a four i
believe this this might actually i might
actually have a decisive advantage at
this point already so um i honestly
don't know what what buck should have
done instead of queen d7 it seems it
seems tough those knights are just uh
exactly really stepping on each other
right
so yes and here after i played d5 i'm
not actually i'm not i'm i'm not very
happy with with uh with how i played
this position out
everything i did looked logical but but
still
i didn't have or i didn't feel i didn't
i didn't have as much as i would like to
have as much advantage as i would like
to have if that makes any sense yeah so
here i have an amazing pawn structure
and and and my main strengths here is
that even if yeah so this move c6 as i
made um or right here yeah i'm not sure
i couldn't i was trying to make it work
without playing c6
but it just it just wasn't working
somehow
black would always get to trade both
both of the c pawns and i couldn't
even that position i'm pretty sure
without without
the c pawns would probably be slightly
better for me but i just i just
yeah it was a really a judgment call
here i decided to go for for for this
structure where
obviously the space is my main strengths
and uh
the only my only issue with this
position is that if black somehow
manages to get their net over to d6 here
um
it's not going to be as clear anymore
because the only way to do that is via
e7 c8 or h8 f7 exactly this is exactly
why i included the move knight f3
earlier so that the knight has to go
back to so that the knight has to go to
g6 right right here actually the engine
does not really like the move knight g6
surprisingly even so i thought it was
the only move here
i guess i think he just wants to give up
the pawn no i guess
the alternative was to take on c5 but i
believe it would be
black would get himself himself in
trouble by by having this this double
pawn structure and
yeah i just felt wrong so i i was i was
totally expecting everything has
happened and here you hear i suddenly
realized that i i missed i missed my
ponderous counter play so here my
original plan was to play 92 right now
knight to f4 maybe yeah exactly 94 was
what i vastly underestimated and here
there's this one knight c4
uh-huh
all right let's take a look at how the
game more or less ended because it seems
that
he didn't get a lot of counter play
after that it just seems
his position was paralyzed yeah well i
think i could have won faster at one at
one moment so if you go a couple of
moves forward
yeah it takes an e3 key
yeah i missed that the shade net f7 id
so here if i just want to avoid knight
h8 knight f7 i should just play rookie
one first and i believe the difference
is that my rook gets to a7 and i'll have
queen e7 in the end so i will i'll apply
a lot of pressure on the seventh string
not in time to get to d6 yeah and black
is not it's one move too short together
knight to d6 because the c74 so i think
this was i i was i was very unhappy with
myself that i missed such an easy plan
and after another five actually black is
right on time
it's probably still losing because once
again
i think this g formula is very important
because i i want to make sure that after
black captures on the five i recaptured
the g pawn
thus creating myself uh creating another
point of entrance for myself which is a
g file
so at this point i think camille was in
a
in a in a time pressure and he
he he tried doing something but
it's really difficult
it's really difficult when you can
barely move especially with no time we
do have another resource for you has won
against uh jj ali morandi the youngsters
on our role today here in group b
nice actually didn't expect
christopher to win he looked like he
might have been in a little bit of a
trouble there but
that's discussion for another time i
guess he pulled he pulled the through
what did you the first one yeah i'm i'm
extremely happy with myself and what can
i say yeah and this is just crushing
right beautiful game ilya always a
pleasure to see you breaking through and
uh good luck in the rest of your games
thank you so much so much sharon thank
you alejandra thank you for joining us
here elia for sure uh let's take a quick
look at what's happened in the last few
minutes abimanu mishra will be joining
us here to explain his game uh let us
just really quickly jump to the alchemy
game because this is one the one that
has us
glued to our seats what on earth is
going on in this position oh my goodness
that king coming to g5 such a beautiful
sight
tonight on f6 what is going on here this
is just absolute madness it feels like
the king on g5 should be checkmated but
the knight on g7 is just a little bit
too
badly placed so i'm a pawn up right as
white i i i'm counting it correctly
you're not even upon
yeah this is crazy no idea what's
happening in this place it's okay we
don't need to know because we have
somebody that plays chess now better
than us grand master abhimanyam mishra
only 12 years old he has won his game
and before we got into that game let us
figure out how he thinks of this
position let's test him out yeah thank
you alejandro yes that's a very it seems
like it's a very strange position with
the king on g5 i mean yeah it's like
very double-edged i'm not sure exactly
what's going on
yeah well your game was uh not
double-edged but much more of a
strategical affair take us through that
one yeah so like in the opening he
played this very interesting queen c2
idea so the main point of this queen c2
is that some you can you keep the
flexibility of knight c3 or knight bd2
and then i had this planet of knight bd7
with b6 which should be seven the idea
of this is eventually some c5 and yeah
here knight bd2 is one of the moves but
i think knight c3 is a bit more testing
because the reason is there are some
lines like in this in
in a semi slab where white goes for this
the same setup with like with the nail
on c3 but he goes for like bishop the
bishop is already on e2 and later he
develop he develops it to d3 so here if
you put the now on c3 it's
it's it's a better version because yeah
the bishop can go to d3 in one move
but yeah he played the snipe this knight
bd2 setup i took on c4 went c5 and this
is
like a also maybe in some lines with the
knight on c3 whenever he plays c5 maybe
d5 yeah
and this is this is a quite fine
position for black and it's fighting
position exactly what i wanted
so he played queen b3 which
queen b3 was a bit interesting but i'm
not exactly sure on what it was doing
because generally in hanging pawn
structure white is trying to attack on
the king side like instead of queen v3 i
think 95 is a bit more accurate
with the idea of like if knight takes c5
details e5 you can win h7
and otherwise there's some
some f4 ideas but i don't think it's
like it's still fine for black but i
think this is more this is a better try
for white
he played queen b3 which i don't think
is really a good move i play i just kept
developing with queen c7
and now the next few moves it was a bit
difficult for both sides to come up with
the plan i just like i brought my bishop
to g7
which prevents d5 like once and for all
well that looks like a very crafty plan
yeah and he played this visually 2 move
which is a bit
i'm not sure like on what it was doing
because d5
it would it still would not work with
the bishop one a2 and in fact it kind of
makes it worse because every time i take
on d5 it it a2 will also hang it just
felt like in the last few moves you were
going the right direction you were
improving your position while he was
creating more weaknesses for himself
yeah
bishop c6 bishop c3 i played a5 the idea
is because i mean with bishop's e3 i
guess white would maybe potentially want
to play a5 against a move like say queen
b7
and yeah queen b7 a5 he gets to trade
off this weak a4 pawn and
yeah it's around equal
and instead of like
and when i play bishop c6 the main idea
is i want to play queen b7 and d5 did
not work because of knight c5 first
because
after knight c5
it was just winning for black because
you win this d5 pawn
yeah so bishop c3 and now i played a5 to
prevent this a5 push
and here you played rook v1 which
i think he completely missed my next
move which was knight d5 right we were
mentioning this in commentary it's such
a nice strategical accomplishment for
you to break out of the third rank yeah
because uh c65 shifts d5 i just went
upon
and yeah he played bishop a1 knight b4
instead of knight b4 and f4 also looked
quite promising but i thought that since
i played a5 b6 it's a bit of weakness
even though my neon d7 is protecting it
i wanted to let my knight go free and
like some e5 ideas now are possible
right and therefore i put my name on b4
and if i drop bc one because after
knight before i have another which was
say knight takes eight so say you make
some random move like say king h1
there's knight takes a2 queen takes a2
bishop takes f3 and now knight takes f3
c4 is going to hang and you could you do
not want to play gtx f3 right
so yeah he played this
after the night before he played rook c1
and now i decided that all of white's
pieces are not looking great as such but
if you give way another move i guess
you'll play bishop b1 with the idea
playing bishop c3 because bishop sees
the directly there is knight d3 and once
bishop b1 happens bishop comes d4 and
yeah
like black's position is still more
preferable but it's not so it's not such
a big advantage definitely but you broke
just yeah i broke the v5
and
knight takes e5 and yeah bishop takes e5
yeah and it seemed like after the
complications especially here after
rookie one white's position was just
fell apart it's not enough activity yeah
and this bishop one v1 it's better than
on a2 but even here it's just staring to
my pawn on g6 and there are a lot of
variations where i was getting trapped
right queen d7 was one of the ways we
were looking at for you to cash in this
must have been your choice
and a smooth sailing yeah and i felt
like this queen eight move was a bit
more was a like a very accurate move
just preventing any counter play on b6
like i think queen e6 is also probably
winning with the ending but i just
didn't want to give him any chance with
my isolated fonts
no this seems absolutely accurate and a
new and nice smooth sailing here you
move to winning two in a row how's it
feel uh to be playing here how's your
performance feel here so far yeah it
feels great to win two games in a row
like after my start and my i played a
not a great game against ali morandi and
yeah that game was
like it was very difficult for me
because i mean he sacked his two pawns
in the opening with this preparation and
i couldn't react well and lost
and yeah it feels amazing to win two in
a row in this very strong tournament
manu always a pleasure to have you here
in the studio always a pleasure to see
you doing well and good luck in the rest
of your games thank you christian
absolutely a lot of pressure on this
young man future of chess in america no
not that big of a deal right well he has
proven himself talented yet again
winning a brilliant game today he is on
his way to join some of these top
players and uh the 27 600 club alejandra
we gotta get back to that king on g yeah
the king on g5 is what really interests
me but uh luckily for us
they reach mu 41 so they're slowing down
yes so now they can more or less
keep
a little bit of sanity as they try to
calculate their their variations out
here of course a big psychological blow
for elshon who must be realizing now
really sinking into him that he's not
winning anymore because perhaps in the
fury of the time pressure as you see
that king marching to g5 you must be
thinking you're winning you're winning
you're winning
and of course we saw many variations in
which he could have picked up an insane
amount of material
but he lets it slip reaches move 41 he
so made his move 40
and now he has to sink into into try to
find a way forward but i i just don't
see it christian we haven't been able to
find it but we're going to let him stew
a little bit longer even as we have
another winner of today's round
christopher you defeating my student
jamiljan ali marandi christopher how'd
that game feel
uh very good i definitely did not expect
to win that position
it felt like he won the battle in the
opening after that you guys transitioned
into more or less balanced end game but
you still had that extra pawn were you
still thinking that you could
potentially turn that into a victory
yeah um i didn't expect to get the extra
pawn so i was very excited once he just
gifted me the extra pawn kind of very
unnecessarily let's actually pull that
uh on the screen right there around here
yeah
yes
yes
when did you feel like uh you're gaining
the advantage you're breaking through
let's say
not here
i thought if like anybody was playing
for the win it would be him but um
knight f6 was the first confusing
decision for me it didn't seem necessary
to just give up this c7 pawn but i
wouldn't really consider it a mistake
and after knight e4
f3
i think he should have won knight f2
because he's threatening knight h3
knight f2 with a draw some sort of a
perpetual right now and if you try to go
to g2 knight to g4 seems to be
quite uh quite strong
yeah what were you uh
what were you preparing to do after
knight to f2
um
maybe just knight b5 and let him take a
draw and just accept the draw yeah i i
don't see anything better yeah right but
he won knight c5 and it feels like he
over
pushed a position i really didn't like
him pushing your king all the way to g3
i didn't understand that at all
yeah i think he might have missed that
after rook d3 i have 4k3 or takes a3
knight takes a3 knight takes a4 knight
c4
i think he might have saw today
it was just a dead draw with king of two
rook detours even this should be a draw
right not that but you should be able to
draw yeah i think this is like better
than what he got in the game in the game
right
because it felt like this end game we
mentioned this on air this move f5 was
very important it felt that this gave
you the greatest amount of winning
chances yeah
and where do you think the decisive
mistake came because we also felt this
one maybe still can be held
uh where did the final mistake come
um
maybe you should have tried to put this
pawn on f5 to
stop my pawns from moving a little bit
once i got my pawn on f5 and my knight
on f4 like this weak f6 and h5 pawn
he couldn't really manage
the situation
right he did a beautiful job there
controlling his knight
not allowing him any counter play and
once the king reaches here
you cannot defend all your opponent
defend any of your pawns and you convert
it quite nicely it just seems like you
make a mistake against christopher you
and you're just gonna go down
yeah at least today
well two victories christopher two draws
no defeats how do you feel uh about your
performance up to this point
very good no complaints no complaints it
is well always uh to see you doing well
here in the studio christopher thank you
very much and good luck in the rest of
your game thank you all right let's
catch up on the rest of the games we
haven't been able to see group a very
much today so i really need to jump to
those we've just been intrigued by
elsian's game by the series of victories
we've had by the youngsters by
christopher you by ami manu by chris
rapka so let's take a quick gander at
what's going on in the rest of the of
the games uh we have this game between
hans niemann and alex slenderman it
feels that either um
either alex is okay or he's totally lost
it's somewhere in between but i think
he's holding quite comfortably after uh
bishop d6 even maybe considering bishop
b6 a more accurate move
and i have trouble believing that
although
i don't know how do we feel about this
end game
i have no real
we've taken c7 you
the pawn end game
is
let's think about this one i actually
have no idea
let me just make some random moves to
illustrate points this should be lost
right alejandro maybe just um
yeah d6 let's see
six king c4
but then you have to do something active
right f5 f5 right it takes an h6 maybe
it's lost but not for no
for my side yeah because you do make
this counter play very quickly right you
take on a7 f7 never helps me
and it's kind of clear that uh this pawn
is going to promote
at least that's what they talk about
let's backtrack a few moves
yeah we're looking at this position
after bishop e3 if bishop b3 bishop to
b6 yeah that's my idea you could you
could play bishop d6 i'm not saying that
you can't no i like this move i like
this bishop to b6 try right because it
it forces white's hand right you don't
have bishop to xb6 yourself love to
trade the bishops off actually and i
feel that if you take on c7 and okay
what if i try to go
by the way i can't take with the bishop
right i i just don't know how i'm going
to deal with king e2 d3 c4 b5 yeah but
that's this is more or less the reason i
wanted to play like this
to get into some sort of pawn end game
this is always going to be a draw if you
move back
and if you take take there's really not
very much i can see what can do
maybe try to do a3 at some point so
let's do the same thing king e3 king d3
sure i'm just going to shuffle yeah
another so i get there
and now i go king to c2
a3 let's see
a3 all right
i guess i'm not really sure which one of
these i'm losing right or how i'm losing
this
well one thing is for sure white still
has the pressure yeah absolutely yeah
yeah rook takes c7 is not the only way
well maybe rook takes seven is the best
move but after that you're not forced to
exchange the bishops potentially you can
go bishop to d2 and continue with your
plan king to e2k to d3 go with the king
to c4 preserve the bishops on the board
and uh i do feel like white has decent
chances to potentially convert this one
i'm going to cheat because we're running
out of time for the program uh the
engine actually thinks it's winning
completely winning completely winning
the partnering game yep yeah well i
haven't really figured out why or how
ah it's it it combines your idea i
wasn't really sure how a3b a3 ever
helped me but it wants to play a4 at
some point some good point okay and at
some point for some reason it's winning
but it is beyond
uh my understanding that's why pawn end
games are so difficult they're so tough
we were mentioning earlier on the in the
program they're so tough it's always
about calculation and it's usually
calculation 20 moves deep yeah yeah
that's the problem it's not we're not
talking about 5 10 moves right we're
talking about some puzzles that you sit
down and it's like okay move 35
it's actually a check yeah all right
then it's winning
and i think alex is more or less
realizing that and and you can see it on
his face he's trying to calculate that
the whole thing right it's not looking
good for him yeah yeah he's starting to
realize that the opponent game is lost
and he has to find something else and
finding something else is not easy
okay let's uh
before we end the program alejandro i
really want to see uh what the fate of
that king on g5 is
it still doesn't look alluring i'll tell
you that
on g5 it's still on g5 but it actually
it just came back um we actually had a
this position rook f1 knight f6 was
played and elsian decided to marry from
a good practical perspective uh take on
f6 take stakes and gave a couple checks
and now he's thinking but it feels that
black's never in danger i can always
perpetual check you i have a feeling
that this king is just too weak yeah and
play something like e5 1396 and start
yeah start pushing for a win but uh on
exciting round today for me
the highlight though four out of four
yes chris rebecca is definitely
dominating the the b group uh he's just
been playing stellar chess right now no
that's amazing yeah and also uh it's a
pleasure to see abhimanyu come back yeah
after a rough start one half a point out
of two uh back-to-back victories is huge
for his confidence no it's huge the way
that he lost he got out prepared but he
said i'm gonna come back i'm gonna come
strong and he's showing how talented he
is the little details of uh playing rook
b1 living the bishop on a2c3 undefended
he says that's enough for me to win i'm
going to put the pieces where they
belong trade the ones that i need to and
immaculate technique they're converting
that pawn let's look at the results of
today's round uh alejandro we're going
to start with the a group yeah the a
group we have sam savion battling it out
against dario spirits aram hakobian is
bound to draw against misha antipov in
any moment hans neiman is putting strong
pressure against alex slenderman ilia
nishnik
soundly defeated camille dragoon after a
couple of strategical mistakes by the
polish player ray robson tried to put
pressure on jeffrey shank but it was
just not enough and the young player
from dallas texas was able to defend and
how about the b group in the b group we
have a lot of decisive results
christopher yu has defeated jj
alimorandi sam hanin has lost them
emanuel mishra and robert miganski has
done the same against chris redka well a
bloody round in the big group so far and
it seems like those last two results uh
also pending and also looking quite
rough well quite an exciting day
alejandro uh tomorrow we're going to be
back with round number five
we're going to be starting at 3 30 p.m
the show is starting at 3 30 p.m but the
actual games which you can find on us
chess champs.com
are on our starting at 1 p.m yep don't
miss the actual really fun stuff for you
guys and we will be here at 3 30 don't
miss it see you tomorrow see you
tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you